Emily Maynard is proving life after
reality fame can be a fairy tale our
Jennifer perros visited the happy mom at
home it's very strange
guys still watching I'm like I can't
believe I did that it just seems like so
long ago because things are so normal
now
like my life in Charlotte is so normal
after failing to find her forever love
on The Bachelor and the Bachelorette
Emily met her husband Tyler at their
church did he watch the show well you
know he's never watched the show but his
brother actually watched it and called
him and was like there's a girl from
Charlotte you had to meet her I think
she's your wife
Wow so he didn't watch The Bachelor he
did not watch The Bachelorette No will
you not allow him to Mike a couple years
we could go back and laugh about it you
know but um yeah he doesn't even like to
watch the show when I'm not on it like
he's just it's just not his deal and you
guys just celebrated her two-year
anniversary feels like we've been
married for a lot longer cuz we have so
many babies on the way the mom to 11
year old Ricky and 1 year old Jennings
is 8 months pregnant with the couple's
second child do you know what you're
having yet no we decided to let this one
be a surprise because we already have a
girl and a boy Emily says all of her
pregnancies have been rough I mean like
sick sick not just like Oh feels so good
so I did what every girl does I went to
social media there were so many women
and so many of them said Dyke Lee just
helped them so I talked to my doctor
about it and he told me it was the only
fda-approved medicine for morning
sickness and it helped me almost
immediately what advice do you have for
Jojo and Jordan now that the cameras are
gone no one should ever take any
bachelor/bachelorette dating advice from
me uh-huh I'm the worst person to give
advice has not worked out well for me in
the past so I would say just don't read
the magazines don't go to an airport
don't go to a grocery store don't ever
go to a target just cocoon yourself in
your house basically if it's the only
way you're gonna get away from it
you